am i right in thinking that you formally
robbie williams bad boy you weren't that
big a christmas fan I was more New
Year's Eve fan but now you were dad and
everything presumably that makes you
Christmas he doesn't know yes I was a
kid and I loved it
then I was a teenager and it was sort of
euphoric and amazing and then I did too
much of that and then had to stop doing
that and then you sort of left with all
the blanks that you were filling in and
then Christmases like sort of you should
be happy now really really happy and
just gonna I'm not and then you've
sought that out for however many years
it takes to sort that out then you meet
your wife and she then I meet your wife
which was weird I know no use for her my
wife and she's just she's just like a
professional memory maker and I've sort
of been taken on this tidal wave of just
incredible memories that she creates now
we've got three kids and I absolutely
love it again apps is my favorite time
of the year oh that's cute I also like
Easter so I'm putting out an Easter
record too
what that you've invented Christmas
traditions what's that about in America
our house is sort of like a British
conch Enclave is that what you call it
it's just full of British people and
then my extended American family and we
decided one day that we'd make up a
tradition and fall our American family
and friends and it's called break the
bread and you have a baguette and we say
it's British but the baguettes already
friend to American people to hold it
either way all the British people start
going break the bread then you get
somebody to karate chop and everybody's
drunk and you completely forget about it
until next Christmas when the Americans
come round they go
we're not going to break the bread it
actually sounds quite fun
[Music]